et on a rencontré un championnat qui
s'obstine qui s'appelaient alice et moon
c'est le champion du monde de lancer de
babouche et regardez le chroniqueur se
sont essayés vraiment dans une grande
arène à ce sport et vous allez voir
mais on a un qui est extrêmement doué
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il va partir pour
les championnats du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
ce matin on a pris une place pour le
volet s'était pas de thalassa le
magazine de la nuit c'était thalassa le
magazine de ta merde moi il m'arrive un
truc de ouf pas il ya un mec qui donne
norvégien champion jet-ski baba il ya
deux bateaux va le cas demain sur la
tête de ma mère mon frère il passe
devant le bateau à fond quand ma mère
aimante d'accueillir car aucune autre ça
vaccaro quand on sait qu'on tente de
retrouver des amis et ce matin je vous
avais dit un truc je vous l'avais dit
celui qui fera le plus beau sous sur un
récompensés et aura le droit à spa vous
avez tous été formidables et c'est
encore une fois je vous le dit notre ami
doc gynéco a gagné ce n'est pas par
éclater le coup concluant lors de cette
épreuve le voilà
et je rappelle qu'il a toujours la
valise diplomatique les rappeurs bravo
on tire assieds-toi en nba si tôt génial
assis toi ça va mon chéri des motos ça
va les gagner
oui le tag est tirée tôt que ce soir tu
aura le droit à un spa on va faire un
petit peu de choix qu'il est très
sportif c'est pas comme ça ben vous
savez qu'on va et on se remettre deux
jours et demi bon les cherry et notre
époque
qui sait si là il ya du public qui nous
attend il ya un champion qui nous attend
du coup il ya alice à moon on le sait le
champion du monde de lancer de la
babouche championne du monde ça se fait
quand tu y vas voir il arrive avec du
public
non ne faites pas août non mais je
rigole pas honorer cyril atteint 420 les
cherry pour lancer de babouche faut
avoir le pied
d'accord allez on y va on va tout
ce n'est pas le but
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
voilà
[Applaudissements]
monsieur mon possible mais qu'elle
ringard
eagle dollar vite
éliminés
[Musique]
ah ouais c'est jamais bon
non
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même l'enfant du pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
le soleil
jour de l'année at il dit on s'arrête
toutefois c'est sûr villes françaises
mais tu disais mais qu'est ce t'as faim
tu es chez toi je restais doc gynéco
elle a toujours ses bottes beau c'est
beau gosse on était frais merci à tous
merci les choses
mais de la babouche d'or et c'est le
motard qui rapport
is not travolta merci à tous et merci à
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez allez
[Applaudissements]
m
bravo retard